hello friends and welcome back to rapid  fire language learning today we're  answering the question  how to stay motivated when learning a  foreign language here are three pieces  of advice for you first  create a time slot on your calendar so  that you know that every day on a given  time you're going to be learning that  language for 15 or 20 minutes or even  one hour  the second thing is to work on reducing  the friction and starting so create a  ritual that can be as simple as  drinking a glass of water or breathing  for three seconds  sit down and start learning the biggest  friction i repeat is actually in  starting and then you get into the flow  motivation is overrated work on your  discipline and motivation  will follow and the third thing is to  create a reward system  if what you do is enjoyable you will  want to do it every day so make sure  that whatever you do  is enjoyable thanks for watching and  i'll see you  in the next video